und damit herzlich willkommen zur neuen
Folge thdl Produkte testen dem einzigen
Format indem ihr eine verlässliche
Aussage darüber bekommt ob die Produkte
aus die Höhle der Löwen tatsächlich was
können und wie immer sind die Produkte
vom geringsten bis zum größten funning
sortiert was bedeutet dran bleiben lohnt
sich wir haben sieben Produkte mit
Sicherheit wieder eine Menge Quatsch
dabei aber hoffentlich auch Produkte die
uns aus dem Hocker hauen und wir fackeln
nicht lange und starten mit dem ersten
Produkt ohne verlegen und ja heute ist
auch das locker dabei wunschkapsel heißt
das erste Produkt von Dr Lars Meyer der
die Idee hatte jedem von uns die
Möglichkeit zu geben seine Supplements
selber und individuell zusammenbasteln
zu können für die Idee wollte er 200.000
€ einsammeln und wäre bereit gewesen 11%
seiner Firma abzugeben was sind
Firmenwert von über 1,8 Millionen Euro
ergeben hätte aber wie gesagt er hat
keinen Deal bekommen nicht mal von Ralf
Dümmel das ganze ist aus dem Glauben
heraus entstanden das Leute am besten
wissen was sie brauchen also ich
Gelenkschmerzen also will ich irgendwas
für meine Gelenke irgendwas für meinen
Kopf also brauche ich das für meinen
Kopf von den Leuten des Ruder selber in
die Hand zu geben und diese Mittel KI
basiert im Internet selber
zusammenstellen zu können und genau das
machen wir jetzt okay wunschkapsel.de
konfiguriere deine Ergänzung alles genau
nach unseren Wünschen wir bauen uns die
perfekte Kapsel um mein Leben zu
verbessern also bessere Gehirnfunktion
um besser zu arbeiten und irgendwas für
den Sport oder den Körper dieser
Kombination baut dann ist das eine
Kapsel aus Acerola Extrakt San PS Bakum
Mint Ginkgo Extrakt und Vitamin A Dose
gestalten und kaufen wir könnten
theoretisch alles drauf schreiben was
ihr wollten ich hatte kurz überlegt
irgendeinen Namen von Mittel drauf zu
schreiben den man besser nicht zu sich
nimmt und der in Deutschland verboten
ist aber das lassen wir deswegen nenne
das Dave Heil Mittel und jetzt bestellen
wir die ganzen Lachs und testen denen
über die nächsten 30 Tage aus bevor wir
uns das ganze aber jetzt in den Schlund
werfen schauen wir erstmal an was
angekommen ist ich muss schon sagen das
sieht ziemlich cool aus Kork Deckel
Aufkleber drüber bedeutet das ist
versiegelt
dann kann man will einfach so aufdrehen
und hier sind die von uns selber
ausgewählten durchsichtigen Pillen und
auch hier starten wir genau jetzt den
Langzeittest schieben uns das rein und
sehen und
in einigen Wochen wieder gucken ob es
tatsächlich was gebracht hat das
Ergebnis seht ihr später im Video
Produkt Nummer 2 namens Kylies Kappa von
Hanna Scheuren und Hannes thunim eine
Idee um Bubble Tea nach Hause zu bringen
für gewöhnlich gibt es Bubble teen nur
in großen Städten oder mittelgroßen
Städten in irgendwelchen Läden es gibt
keine Möglichkeit wenn ihr auf dem Dorf
und es einfach ganz entspannt von zu
Hause zu trinken und Kellys Kappa sollte
Abhilfe schaffen für alle Leute in der
großen Stadt ist natürlich kein Problem
Bubble te direkt von zu Hause zu trinken
weil das überlieferdienste wie z.B
wollte zu bestellen ist sie hier Papa
Platte jeden Tag gesucht haben sie
200.000 € für 15 % Ihres Unternehmens
was einen Unternehmenswert von
1,33333 Millionen Euro ergeben hätte
bekommen haben sie leider keinen Deal
vor allem mit der Begründung dass die
Lösung etwas zu teuer fanden für diese
Box die uns 23,99 € kostet gibt es
einzeln zu bestellen oder im Abo und
enthalten sollten fünf Bubble Tea für zu
Hause sein ich bin ja nicht bescheuert
und hat in meinem Leben schon ungefähr
alles ausgegoogelt und alle Margen
gegoogelt deswegen weiß ich dass die
Marge auf Bubble Tea geisteskrank ist
wir blenden euch hier einfach mal kurz
ein was so ein paar bubbles in der Metro
Kosten das ganze ist noch deutlich
günstiger in dem Moment wo man sich mit
irgendwelchen Leuten verpartner hat
bestimmte Mengen abnimmt genauso wie
dies mit Sicherheit auch machen werden
also die Marge auf diese fünf Bubble
Tees für 23,99 € ist schon wirklich
krass und weil die Löwen das auch wissen
war das mit Sicherheit ein großer
Kritikpunkt dass man das nicht etwas
günstiger macht in dieser Box befindet
sich einmal eine Art Marmeladenglas in
der wir den Bubble die anrichten sollen
das erste was mir auffällt es ist
deutlich zu klein zumindest für meinen
Geschmack in einem normalen
bubbley-laden kann man die größten
auswählen soweit ich weiß geht es auf
der Webseite nicht und das hier sind
vielleicht 300 ml was mir deutlich zu
wenig ist weil ich gerne mehr hätte in
diesem Marmeladenglas finden wir
typische Teebeutel dann haben wir einen
weiteren Karton
in dem ganzen popping boah was sind also
die Dinger
machen unter Sirup in verschiedenen
Geschmacksrichtungen
[Musik]
also netterweise wurde Popcorn
mitgeschickt das sind nicht mehrere
Popcorn neues ein riesiger Popcorn sehr
nett aber werde ich nicht verspeisen
also das wirkt irgendwie so ein bisschen
so selbst abgefüllt was sich er jetzt
erstmal nicht so richtig nice und
hochwertig anfühlt dazu die Sache mit
dem Popcorn und hier drin haben wir
weiter kleine Broschüren die
wahrscheinlich irgendwas erklären und
zwei Strohhalme also all in all muss ich
sagen ich finde so ein bisschen nicht
ganz perfekt um ehrlich zu sein und dazu
kommt was ich jetzt schon weiß es fehlt
diese Schicht oben drauf ja die wollen
auf Plastik verzichten ne aber es fehlt
diese Schicht darauf womit man den
Bubble Tea entsiegelt das ist das die
eine Aktion die einen Bubble Tiefe für
mich zu einem Bubble Team macht und die
wird hier bei garantiert fehlen weil sie
auch nicht wie man das hätte lösen
können aber ich glaube das wird mir
fehlen und jetzt testen wir das Ganze
und schauen ob es schmeckt den haben wir
schon mal vorbereitet natürlich mit dem
mitgelieferten Teesorten und jetzt
probieren wir einen dieser beiden hier
nachzubauen das sind Originale aus dem
Laden direkt hier aus Köln quasi frisch
wie im Laden zubereitet damit wir den
perfekten Vergleich haben die ist aus
dem Laden und zu Hause mit keines
Körperschaft benutzen den mitgelieferten
Cup und uns etwas Eis rein mit dem
grünen Tee auf
[Musik]
ja im Handumdrehen gemixt sieht aus wie
ein echter Bubble Tea
riecht wie ein echter Bubble Tea
und schmeckt wie ein echter Bubble Tee
ich meine das ist ja kein kein Wunder
was hier passiert wenn man sich ein
Bubble Team im Laden holt das ist genau
so werden die eben gemacht schmeckt das
Produkt ja war die Customer Experience
geil nein glaube ich dass ich durchsetzt
auf keinen Fall bin ich zu teuer ja denn
z.B auf irgendwelchen anderen Webseiten
dafür muss man nicht mal in die Metro
gibt es diesen Riesen bucket für 20 €.
was ungefähr so viel kostet wie dieses
ganze Ding hier nur man bekommt deutlich
mehr also es gibt quasi genau dieses
Produkt in dem man sich selber im
Internet zusammen sucht für viel weniger
Geld und deswegen glaube ich nicht daran
und ich selber wird kein zweites Mal
kaufen Produkt Nummer drei nennt sich
flachsback von den Gründern Lukas
Richter und Jens Thiel mit dem großen
Ziel mit dem Luftpumpen Markt zu
revolutionieren ein Viertel des Gewichts
und dabei selbe Punkt Leistung wie eine
Fußpumpe um Luftmatratzen und
Schwimmtiere und alles was man so
aufblasen will on the go leichter mit
weniger Gepäck aufblasen zu können
gesucht haben die beiden 130.000 €
werden bereit gewesen 10 % ihr
Unternehmens abzugeben macht den
Firmenwert von 1,3 Millionen Euro
bekommen hätten sie einen Deal über
130.000 Euro hätten aber 25% abgeben
müssen dieser Deal ist in der Sendung
zustande gekommen und danach aber leider
geplatzt ob der Traum der pumpenmarkt
Revolution aber auch Platz schauen wir
uns jetzt mal gemeinsam an denn ich bin
der
pumpenmarkt Richter das ist das Produkt
kommt in Plastik einfachpakt pro es gibt
nämlich zwei verschiedene flachsberg
eine für sehr geübte Pumpen Benutzer wie
mich und äh eine Basic Variante in Flate
just one breath 140 Liter fast diese
Pumpe und soll ja angeblich mit einem
Atemzug befüllbar sein also Packmaß ist
wirklich schön klein die Düsen und
Adapter sind dabei die Schläuche sind
auch dabei und das hier ist das magische
Gerät
und klar es gibt entspanntere Sachen als
mit dem Mund eine ganze Luftmatratze auf
zu pusten aber es geht schon immer und
es geht so gut dass ich mich immer aktiv
dafür entscheide keine Luftpumpe keine
Akku Luftpumpe keine Fuß Luftpumpe
einfach gar nichts mehr zu nehmen weil
ich mich lieber einfach 5 Minuten
hinsetzen die aufpuste mit dem Mund und
dann dafür aber nicht schleppen muss wir
machen den Selbstversuch
das Ding funktioniert das Ding
funktioniert aber glaube ich besser für
größere Matratzen für alles in meinem
Anwendungsbereich das ist die
Luftmatratze mit der ich tatsächlich auf
der Fahrradtour auf irgendwelchen
Camping Trips quasi immer unterwegs bin
brauche ich das überhaupt nicht in dem
Moment wo man aber Luxus Camping mäßig
unterwegs ist und Platz für eine
doppelte Matratze hat hat man auch Platz
für eine elektrische Luftpumpe oder für
irgendeine andere Luftpumpe also das
Ding funktioniert ich brauche gar nicht
und in meinem Fall geht's auch nicht
schneller als mit dem Mund und nach
dieser unheimlichen Anstrengung erstmal
eine kurze Erfrischung mit dem Partner
des heutigen Videos ja Flasche auf Port
hoch
[Musik]
eigentlich der perfekte Kandidat für
dhdl gewesen mit einer Idee so einfach
wie genial war es aber nie und wird es
auch nicht sein und das aus gutem Grund
die Idee hat nämlich nicht nur meine
sondern auch schon viele daily routins
von euch verändert und er ab ist als
täglicher Begleiter mit euch in der
Schule der Uni auf der Arbeit oder wo
auch immer ihr hingeht ist eben mehr als
einfach nur Wasser trinken das Stichwort
heißt Retro das alles riechen und
bedeutet so viel wie geschmecken zu 80%
in unserer Nase und das ist der Trick
durch das Saugen an diesem wunderbaren
kleinen Silikon Aufsatz wird das Wasser
nicht nur aus der Flasche in euren Mund
transportiert sondern auch Luft in
diesem Duft portiert zirkulieren lassen
dass ich das Gefühl gibt etwas mit
Geschmack zu trinken obwohl er
eigentlich nur pures Wasser trinken
bedeutet im Umkehrschluss wir haben die
freie Wahl aus über 30 verschiedenen
Luft von Apfel über Kokos bis Kirsche
oder in meinem Fall da wenn der lemonate
obwohl wir am Ende immer das gleiche
Wasser trinken wir können Sie mir
glauben oder nicht der erste Griff wenn
ich morgen ins Büro komme geht an die
erdflasche denn ich habe eine Sucht für
einen Softdrink den ich nun endlich den
Kampf angesagt gesagt haben über den
ersten Link in der Videobeschreibung und
mit dem Code Dave erhaltet ihr für die
nächsten vier Wochen zehn Prozent aufs
gesamte Sortiment wolltet ihr eher ab
also schon immer mal ausprobieren oder
wirklich sehr einfach einfach mehr
Wasser trinken dann ist das hier die
Chance Produkt Nummer 4 nennt sich
sockländer von den Gründern Nadine
letspor und Tobias Ross die Idee im
Prinzip so einfach wie genial eine Socke
die eure Füße und alles im Bereich der
Schuhe davor schützen sollen ungebetene
Gäste in die Schuhe zu bekommen jeder
von euch der bei Oma schon mal Rasen
gemäht hat kennt das Problem dass der
Rasen der hinten am Finger vorbei fliegt
oder der aufgewirbelt wird mit in die
Schule kommt gesucht haben die beiden
60.000 € für 20%, was sind 400 von 300
000 € ergeben hätte bekommen haben sie
die 60.000 € aber für 25%, was nimmt
wird von 240.000 € macht und das ist das
Produkt nicht in meiner Größe und das
aus gutem Grund und das könnte uns
vielleicht Hinweis darauf geben wie gut
die Produkte tatsächlich angekommen sind
egal wo wir im Internet geschaut haben
gibt es diese Socken nicht mehr in Größe
also in 45 wahrscheinlich nach Größe die
viele Leute haben die draußen arbeiten
jetzt komisch an ist aber wahrscheinlich
wirklich so Verpackung ziemlich einfach
wie man es von Socken gewohnt ist aber
ziemlich schick so ein dunkles Grün
erinnert irgendwie an Socken und Sachen
die für draußen gedacht sind hier auf
dem Bild sieht man schon irgendeinem
Bauarbeiter der irgendwas schneidet wo
staubt und man sieht das Produkt auch
schon angewendet im Prinzip der Prototyp
sah nämlich auch so aus als wären zwei
Socken die einfach zusammengenäht sind
bei dem eine Schicht über die Schuhe
hinaus zu klappen ist so dass einfach
keinen direkten Eingang Richtung Socken
gibt hier mit so Gummi oder
silikonstopern damit der Schaft den man
umlegt auch wirklich nicht rutscht das
Produkt also ein paar kostet 12,99 €
sollte das wirklich die Lösung für ein
großes Problem sein finde ich den Preis
auch ziemlich okay und genau das nehmen
wir jetzt mal genauer unter die Lupe
grundsätzlich trage ich ja nur
Birkenstock das geht in diesem Fall
nicht denn die sind komplett offen
begreifen auf meine original seven vs
wild Schuhe zurück die ich nicht nur nur
einen Tag in Staffel 1 benutzt habe
sondern auch beim zweitversuch der kommt
in den nächsten Wochen also vergesst
nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren um das
nicht zu verpassen darum geht es aber
jetzt nicht sondern um sockländer die
ziehen wir ganz normal an steigen in den
Schuh machen ihn zu und können jetzt die
zweite Schicht umstülpen über den Schuh
und der ist quasi direkt sicher
abgesiedelt richtig geil vom ersten
Gefühl Socken super bequem haben hier
unten so ein extra Petting den stülpe
ich nicht drüber und jetzt kommt der
Test hier die Socken an genau wie sie
sein sollen über den Schuh und auf
dieser Seite offen und jetzt können wir
anfangen Outdoor Arbeiten zu erledigen
[Musik]
Vergleich aus mit sockländer ohne
sockländer
weniger eindrucksvoll als ich mir
vorgestellt habe aber man muss sagen es
hat perfekt funktioniert die Schuhe
waren in unserem Extremfall jetzt nach
wenigen Minuten komplett voll und für
Leute die das tatsächlich im Alltag oder
beim Heimwerken am Wochenende beim
Rasenmähen damit Probleme haben ist
dieses Produkt absolut top und für mich
ein absolutes Wedding Produkt eins der
besten Produkte die wir jemals hier
getestet haben zurück zu wunschkapsel
und dem Langzeittest ich habe diese
Dinger über die letzten Tage gesnackt
diesmal Smarties fünf am Tag die mir
vorgeschrieben oder angeraten sind sind
gar nicht so wenig und tatsächlich habe
ich hin und wieder mal vergessen sie zu
nehmen weil ich noch gar nicht darauf
konditioniert bin nichtsdestotrotz mit
links die Tage sehr gut ob ich jetzt
weniger krank geworden bin dadurch oder
ob es mir wirklich deutlich besser geht
muss man wahrscheinlich über einen noch
längeren Zeitraum sehen ich bin aber
fest davon überzeugt dass alles was ich
bestellt habe auch wirklich in den
Kapseln ist der Versand ging mega
schnell und wenn man eh viele
Nahrungsergänzungsmittel nimmt kann das
hier eine richtig geile Option sein
einfach alles in einer Kapsel zu haben
Bestellprozess super Personalisierung
super Versand super die Kapseln super
alles in bester Ordnung und für mich ein
richtig gutes und natürlich ein winning
Produkt Nummer 5 von den Gründern
Frederic Felix und Raul mit dem großen
Ziel dem bierpon Markt der seit Jahren
besteht und immer gleich ist mit ihrem
Produkt namens Freds zu revolutionieren
gesucht haben sie 125 000 € werden
bereit gewesen 25,1% abzugeben was knapp
unter 500.000 € gibt bekommen haben sie
ihre gesuchten 125 000 € haben dafür
aber 30 % abgegeben und das aber nicht
an einen Löwen sondern an Ralf Dümmel
und Carsten Maschmeyer zusammen was sich
ziemlich gut anhört und das hier ist das
Produkt in schöner einfacher Verpackung
coole Farben alles wunderbar die Höhle
der Löwen steht drauf das Problem dass
die drei lösen wollten waren dass das
Bier bei mir spielen über den gesamten
Party Abend hinweg nie wirklich kalt ist
oder kalt bleibt besonders wenn Leute
schlecht vier Punkten spielen so wie ich
dann kann das schon mal dauern bis man
Bier trinken dann ist es aber nicht nur
abgestanden sondern warm und genau da
soll dieses Produkt angreifen finde ich
eine ziemlich coole Idee und tatsächlich
hatten alle bis auf einen Löwen oder
einen Löwin auch Lust da rein zu
investieren also das Produkt kam
ziemlich gut an Freds eiskalt
erfrischend selbst kühlende
Mehrwegbecher das 3er Set für 12,99 6er
Set also noch drei in anderen Farben für
19,99 das gesamte Konzept statt
Eiswürfel mit Kühlflüssigkeit in der
Becher Wand also eine doppelte Wand die
ist uns ermöglicht den ganzen Abend über
kühle Getränke zu haben so zumindest die
Theorie die Form sieht jetzt schon mal
so aus als könnte das gut funktionieren
man sieht auch in der Mitte das ist eine
doppelte Wand gibt und das ist ein
bisschen dicker wird aber anderen für
sich und ziemlich cooles Produkt bevor
wir das natürlich testen können kommt
das jetzt in Eisfach und dann schauen
wir uns an wie die Temperaturentwicklung
ist und ob wir tatsächlich schönes
kaltes Bier spielen können um die
Funktionalität wirklich unter die Lupe
nehmen zu können müssen wir natürlich
unter echten Bedingungen testen das
bedeutet Raumtemperatur einmal
ungekühlten Becher und einmal im kühlten
Becher dasselbe Getränk der selben Start
Temperatur
vor allem aber auch in derselben Menge
so das ist unser Testszenario das hier
in den ungekühlten Becher
das hier kommt in den gekühlten Becher
die Starttemperatur beträgt 5,0 im
gekühlten Becher und in der kurzen Zeit
2,7 ist kühl die jetzt sogar weiter
runter also es geht direkt los und das
lassen wir jetzt so stehen geben euch
Updates und während wir warten schauen
wir ob die welche hat tatsächlich für
bierpong geeignet herzlich willkommen
zum traurigsten hier Punkt Turnier der
Welt ich alleine gegen diese drei Becher
das funktioniert ich bin zwar
gleichzeitig der Gewinner und der
Verlierer dieses Video aber wir Punkt
mäßig halten diese Becher schon mal was
sie versprechen das kältemäßig so
aussieht schauen uns jetzt noch mal an
die ersten 10 Minuten sind rum in
unserem gekühlten Becher 2,5 Grad und in
unserem nicht gekühlten Becher
mittlerweile 8,8 Grad
nach einer Stunde und 20 Minuten haben
wir 4,4 Grad Unterschied und das
gekühlte Getränk oder aus dem kühlbecher
ist noch genießbar und das andere nicht
auf der anderen Seite wäre so lang für
eine bierpondrunde braucht sollte sich
eher neues Spiel anstatt neues Equipment
suchen alles in allem es hat
funktioniert wir konnten spielen und die
Getränke sind kühler und das auch über
längere Zeit Produkt Nummer 6 nennt sich
super von den Gründern Michael gut und
Patrick Fuchs die mit ihren Mini
koffeinbeutel den Energy Markt
revolutionieren wollten für den Deal
haben sie sich 150.000 € vorgestellt
werden bereit dafür 50% abzugeben und
genau dieser Deal ist so zustande
gekommen dass ich schon wirklich krass
finde weil 50% seines Unternehmens
abzugeben von wirklichen commitment ist
so sehen die Produkte hier aus vier
verschiedene Geschmacksrichtungen und
jeder der schon mal eine packungs
gesehen hat er kennt das Design wieder
denn es ist quasi das gleiche Konzept
mit anderen Inhaltsstoffen ist in
Deutschland mittlerweile nicht mehr
verkauft aus welchen Gründen auch immer
es ist auf jeden Fall irgendeine Art von
Nikotin und deswegen deswegen mit
Vorsicht zu behandeln dass sie es
Koffein und soll mit Sicherheiten
Alternative dazu sein aber grundsätzlich
für Leute die smooth haben wollen und
uns in Deutschland kaufen wollen könnte
das eine coole Variante sein ich rate
grundsätzlich jedem von euch dazu ab in
irgendeiner Form sich irgendwas auf die
Schleimhäute zu tun auch bevor ich das
getestet habe einfach aus dem Grund dass
ich überhaupt keine Ahnung habe das
nicht vernünftig einschätzen kann und
ihr euch da vorher informieren solltet
und das bitte auch erstmal ab 18 auch
wenn hier kein Nikotin drin ist naja
dann wollen wir mal fresh nennt das ist
zumindest das womit ich am meisten
Erfahrung bei original Snus habe ich
sag's noch mal ich rate jedem von euch
dazu ab vor allem unter 18 auf keinen
Fall
naja und legt sich das hier so hin
fängt leicht an zu brennen wie es auch
von Snooze kenne ich habe heute auch
noch keinen Koffein zu mir genommen also
gar nichts ich müsste es wirklich merken
Fazit ja es funktioniert ja es schmeckt
die Gerüche die Geschmäcker sind gut
wunderbar der Bock darauf hat es
funktioniert ist ein gutes Produkt ich
bleibe weiterhin nicht bei smooth weil
es in Deutschland nicht erlaubt ist
kommen wir endlich zu Produkt Nummer 7
dem Produkt auf dass ich mich seit
Monaten am meisten gefreut habe Lock hat
oder Lock hat Wallet kennt jeder von
euch über tiktok und andere Social Media
Kanäle von den Gründern Aron rau und
Jonas Weber gesucht haben sie 200.000 €
für 15 %. was einen Firmenwert von 1,333
Millionen Euro ergibt bekommen haben sie
zumindest in der Sendung 200.000 € für
25% ihres Unternehmens was nimmt von 800
000 € ergibt danach wurde auf tiktok
aufgeklärt dass der Deal so nicht
zustande gekommen ist wurde glaube ich
eine Kooperation eingegangen es wurde
geholfen lockert wallets in den Handel
zu bekommen so dass man sie Kaufland
oder wo auch immer kaufen konnte und
genau diese Lok hat schauen wir uns an
ich weiß schon dass wir jetzt direkt
hier beim Auspacken die erste
Optimierung sehen werden und wir sehen
warum das ein Unterschied macht auf
wirklich Kleinigkeiten zu achten wir
packen diese Lasche und ziehen das ganze
hier raus und haben eine unheimlich nice
viel geilere Unboxing experience eine
ganz andere Verbindung zum Produkt ist
fühlt sich viel persönlicher cooler und
durchdachte an als jedes andere Produkt
dass wir hier bisher in diesem Format
ausgepackt haben das hier ist der
Magnethalter der kann irgendwo
positioniert werden das ist das Lock hat
wallett so sieht das hier aus das sind
die verschiedenen Module wir können das
Gummiband hier abnehmen und uns das so
zusammenbasteln wie wir das haben wollen
und ich werde das ganze jetzt befüllen
und einfach über die nächste Zeit
benutzen und schauen ob es wirklich
Alternative zu meinem Portemonnaie sein
kann denn ich bin auch Freund von
flachen und kleinen portemonnaise aber
dieses Ding hat natürlich deutlich
weniger Funktion als das lockert und
deswegen testen wir das über die
nächsten Tage und dann gibt es ein Fazit
über die letzten Tage habe ich Lock Card
komplett bei mir geführt in der
Hosentasche in meiner Umhängetasche
einfach überall ich war feiern
Mittagessen in der Stadt einkaufen und
habe genug Zeit gehabt Lock hat wirklich
unter die Lupe zu nehmen und ich kann
direkt sagen was mir nicht gefällt und
das war das Schlüsselfach und nicht weil
es nicht funktioniert sondern weil ich
einfach zu viele Schlüssel habe das
Bargeld war und das Kartenfach ist aber
unheimlich Handy bedeutet es ist noch
mal schmaler und ich muss sagen ich bin
richtig überzeugt all in all ich bin
richtig zufrieden mit meinem Lock hat
Wallet ich finde das Unternehmen richtig
geil ich finde die Videos richtig geil
finde das absolut unterstützenswert und
Wechsel jetzt offiziell von meinem alten
Leder Portemonnaie auf das lockert
wurdet ach du heiliges Kanonenrohr was
war das mal wieder für eine Folge tolle
Produkte schlechte Produkte viel funding
wenig gar kein verlinkt und eine Menge
Spaß für mich und euch wenn es euch
gefallen hat lasst mir gerne ein Like da
vergesst nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren
und lasst mich vor allem in den
Kommentaren wissen ob ihr mich mal mit
einem eigenen Produkt bei Höhle der
Löwen sehen würdet denn ich arbeite
daran etwas wir sehen uns nächste Woche
macht es gut ciao
[Musik]